this is the new departure point for a
British evacuation fights leaving Sudan
the last departure point where I
deciding a military base in the capital
just outside
to feel very unsafe after a Turkish
military plane was came under Fire
trying to land a senior military source
told us that the flight did not follow
its expected route and thus they saw as
an enemy flight and it was fired at but
now people have had to come all the way
here now the journey by road is long it
can be up to 19 hours 15 hours 12 hours
depending on the checkpoints depending
on the road and so people are exhausted
they've come a very long way some of
them have made it to the military base
in the capital and I've been told that
that's no longer operational and have
come here others have had to leave
family members behind who aren't British
citizens and the the main sentiment here
is that families are being torn apart
that there aren't enough Provisions
being made for those who are either
married to British people or have
biometric cards or have visas for our he
has been for British citizens but what
that has meant is that there's no room
for evacuation for those that they love